zusammen bei zdf heute live und ihren
live stream zu aktuellen ereignissen und
diskussionen und da haben wir heute
längere zeit nach amsterdam geschaut wo
sich die europäische arzneimittelagentur
in einem speziellen gremium zusammen
gefunden hat um zu entscheiden wie es
weitergehen soll mit dem astra zeneca
impfstoff viele europäische länder gut
die hälfte hatten ja verzichtet mit
diesem impfstoff weiter zu impfen weit
ist einige ungeklärte todesfälle gab
womöglich im zusammenhang mit diesem
impfstoff es kam dazu hirn thrombosen
und die europäische arzneimittelagentur
wollte prüfen wie hoch das risiko bei
diesem impfstoff tatsächlich ist das
fazit dass sie heute getroffen haben war
dieser impfstoff hat ein gewisses risiko
wie hoch kann man nicht sagen aber der
nutzen überwiegt was da genau
beschlossen wurde erklärt uns gleich
andrea maurer wir warten hier auf die pk
mit gesundheitsminister jens spahn aus
berlin der gleich wahrscheinlich
verkünden wird wie deutschland weiter
vorgeht was die anderen europäischen
länder vorhaben sage ich euch gleich
aber erstmal eine zusammenfassung wie
gesagt von der kollegin andrea maurer
heißt die europäische
arzneimittelbehörde ema heute ihre
risikobewertung verkündet geht es um
nicht weniger als die zukunft eines
dringend gebrauchten impfstoffes
wir sind zu einer klaren
wissenschaftlichen einschätzung gekommen
dass ist ein sicherer und wirksamer
impfstoff
das was wir gerade sehen ist eine
situation die zu erwarten war
wenn sie millionen menschen impfen ist
es unvermeidbar dass seltene oder
ernsthafte zwischenfälle und
erkrankungen unmittelbar nach der
impfung auftreten
der impfstoff soll es schnell wieder
verkauft werden allerdings mit
warnhinweis auf seltene fälle von
blutgerinnseln so die iaea kurz nach der
entscheidung will eigentlich der
gesundheitsminister vor die presse
treten
der termin wird verschoben der beschluss
lägen nicht vor heißt es
erleichterung und sorge unterdessen in
deutschen impfzentren wie hier in
trostberg bayern erleichterung weil sie
astrazeneca wieder für impfen können
aber auch sorge weil niemand weiß wie
schnell die verzögerung durch den
impfstoff behoben sind
versuchen die 1200 termine die wir seit
montag abgesagt haben liefert sofort
einzubestellen mit gewissen
schwierigkeiten dass die leute natürlich
unter umständen jetzt im moment nicht
erreichbar sind und dass natürlich der
impfstoff jetzt wieder einen gewissen
vertrauensschwund hat drei tage lang lag
astrazeneca nach dem impfstoff
sprichwörtlich auf eis in den
kühlschränken der impfärzte politisch
wird es nun vor allem darum gehen den
image schaden zu begrenzen
ich war mir aber trotzdem sorgen wie
astrazeneca noch will deswegen so viel
wie möglich über die hausärzte zu
kämpfen
wenn der hausarzt ist der mediator für
die akzeptanz an der stelle der kann
auch am besten einschätzen ob derjenige
patient gut geeignet ist schlecht
geeignet
immer lauter werden auch die stimmen die
auf eine schnelle zulassung und
bestellung des russischen impfstoff
sputnik wie drängen der seit zum teil
besser als bereits zugelassene
impfstoffe sagt markus söder heute eine
klare impfstrategie die wird beim
virtuellen impf gipfel im kanzleramt
morgen dringend gesucht ja und wir
warten darauf dass sich der
gesundheitsminister jetzt doch noch
äußert 20 uhr wurde als pressekonferenz
zeit angegeben
eure fragen und die einschätzungen zu
der pressekonferenz beantwortet uns die
soeben auch schon doktor christoph
spinner oberarzt in münchen so jetzt
haben wir kurz das bild gewechselt das
ist ja nicht dass das leere pult in
berlin wo wir darauf warten da ist dr
christoph spinner oberarzt in münchen
beauftragter pandemie beauftragter des
klinikums rechts der isar schön dass ich
nochmal dabei sind so ich wollte ganz
kurz noch mal zusammenfassen was
passiert ist seitdem wir das letzte mal
gesprochen haben das ist gut zwei
stunden her da haben wir uns angeguckt
was die ema verkündet hat seitdem dass
jede menge passiert
die ticker hier unsere nachrichten
ticker sind sie ein bisschen heiß
gelaufen also zum beispiel können wir
feststellen dass einige europäische denn
da schon gesagt haben
wir nehmen die impfung wieder auf
frankreich zum beispiel italien möchte
die impfung wieder aufnehmen
schweden wird weiter am stopp der
astrazeneca im vom festhalten man
benötige noch ein paar tage sagte der
leiter der städtischen
gesundheitsbehörde carlsson dann gibt
es ist aber andere meldungen dass ich
zum beispiel boris johnson mit diesen
impfstoff morgen impfen lassen möchte
quasi demonstrativ und es gibt auch
jetzt die idee haben wir gerade auch
schon ein bisschen von herrn söder
gehört im beitrag das um diesen
impfstoff der ja nicht das beste image
gerade zu haben scheint den wieder nach
vorne zu bringen auch zu benutzen
quasi diese die impfstoff reihenfolge
oder die in freien völker aufgehoben
werden soll dass jeder der möchte sich
mit diesem impfstoff impfen lassen
können soll was halten sie denn von
dieser idee ich glaube gerade in der
zeit steigender infektionszahlen kommt
es darauf an dass wir wirklich jeden tag
nutzen um so viele menschen wie möglich
zu impfen denn die impfung ist und
bleibt der einzige schutz nicht nur den
geben schweren kursverlauf sondern
natürlich auch die gesellschaft für
weitere infektionen zu schützen
der astra zeneca impfstoff ist sicher
und was wir auch der forschung wussten
ist das sehr wirksam ist das hat die
europäische arzneimittelbehörde heute
auch noch mal bestätigt und eine der
strategien könnte natürlich sein dass er
erst als senica impfstoff auch breiter
vor allem über hausarztpraxen verfügbar
gemacht wird war zuletzt diskutiert und
der große vorteil dieses impfstoffes
liegt auch darin dass er bei
kühlschranktemperatur gelagert und auch
transportiert werden kann während die m
rna impfstoffe von wir unter kaiser und
moderner tiefgekühlt bzw ultra
tiefgekühlt werden müssen was die
verabreichung eigentlich nur über in
zentren sinnvoll möglich macht so und
wir warten darauf was sich in berlin tut
da habe ich gerade gesagt bekommen da
ist das bild also tatsächlich wird das
pult eingerichtet das sieht so aus dass
es gleich losgehen könnte wir sind
gespannt was der gesundheitsminister und
jetzt gleich zu verkünden hat es hieß
aus berlin man wurde sich nicht sofort
nach der pressekonferenz der
europäischen arzneimittelagentur melden
sondern erstmal den bericht abwarten die
mit den anderen gesundheitsministerien
der länder besprechen und sich dann an
die öffentlichkeit wenden das wird jetzt
gleich der fall sein
also wir haben uns heute schon viel
unterhalten darüber auch mit doktor
christoph spinner
über die frage wie sicher dieser
impfstoff ist was mit den risiken ist
jetzt hat gerade lese ich hier in
unserem news-ticker schweden noch mal
einen todesfall in zusammenhang mit
diesem impfstoff möglicherweise gemeldet
also auch eine ähnliche erkrankung einen
hinterraum große dass ich weiß dass
solche meldungen immer wieder in den
medien jetzt gemeldet werden herr doktor
spinner und und man darüber berichtet
aber vielleicht können sie nochmal einen
ordnen wie groß dieses risiko jetzt
tatsächlich zu sein scheint dass so eine
hirn thrombose auftritt also die singles
venenthrombose und die es jetzt geht ist
eine sehr seltene erkrankung sie ist
bislang nicht als spezifische
nebenwirkung von impfstoffen bekannt
aber man kann natürlich im zeitlichen
zusammenhang mit den impfstoffen auch
jetzt nicht ohne weiteres ausschließen
zumindest nicht mit letzter gewissheit
das ist auch einen zusammenhang geben
könnte die ursprüngliche meldungen des
paul-ehrlich-instituts am montag der
dann auch nicht zuletzt selber prüfungen
noch mal geführt hatten waren sieben
fälle bei 1,6 millionen geimpften
menschen also wirklich eine sehr seltene
erkrankung sie geht üblicherweise mit
starken ungewöhnlichen kopfschmerzen ein
er kann aber von weitere neurologischen
symptomen begleitet werden und die
europäische arzneimittelagentur hat
heute auch sehr präzise ausgeführt je
mehr menschen geimpft werden das zu mehr
seltene nebenwirkungen werden auch
berichtet dass an sich finde ich
eigentlich beruhigende nachrichten das
bedeutet auch dass die arzneimittel
sicherheitsüberwachung funktioniert die
impfenden ärzte innen und ärzte melden
entsprechende arzneimittel
nebenwirkungen den pharmazeutischen
unternehmen und behörden und wir können
darauf reagieren so herr doktor jetzt
hat gerade der bundesgesundheitsminister
das pult betreten wir schalten darüber
nach berlin
sehr geehrte damen und herren die
entscheidung der ema bestätigt die
sicherheit und die qualität des
impfstoffs von astra zenica das ist eine
gute nachricht die entscheidung
bestätigt aber auch die einschätzung des
paul-ehrlich-instituts zu seltenen aber
schwerwiegenden ereignissen ärztinnen
und ärzte müssen über das risiko von
hirn venenthrombosen bei frauen unter 55
jahren informiert werden damit sie
ihrerseits die impfwilligen entsprechend
aufklären können die europäische
arzneimittelagentur ema hat sich daher
heute für eine entsprechende ergänzung
der fach und patienteninformationen
entschieden
ich habe darüber im anschluss mit
unseren europäischen partnern beraten
und mit dem gesundheitsministerin und
gesundheitsminister der bundesländer wie
und auf welcher grundlage die ema zu
dieser entscheidung kam wegen gleicher
professor psycho tag vom
paul-ehrlich-institut darlegen uns
bestätigt die analyse der ema in unserem
vorgehen
es war richtig die impfung mit astra
zenica vorsorglich auszusetzen ist die
auffällige häufung der fälle dieser sehr
seltenen thrombosen art analysiert
worden ist
ärztinnen und ärzte ohne diese
information weiter impfen zu lassen wäre
aus unserer sicht schwer zu verantworten
gewesen denn die impfenden ärzten und
ärzte müssen bescheid wissen und
bescheid wissen können über mögliche
nebenwirkungen und risiken gegenüber dem
impfwilligen besteht bei einer
staatlichen impfkampagne auch eine
besondere sorgfaltspflicht
sie müssen über bekannte auch neu
erkannte mögliche nebenwirkungen
aufgeklärt sein wenn sie sich für die
impfung entscheiden auch wenn diese sehr
selten vorkommen deshalb war es nach den
erkenntnissen und der empfehlung des
paul-ehrlich-instituts geboten die
impfung vorübergehend und vorsorglich
auszusetzen
ich habe am montag an dieser stelle
gesagt dass uns das auch mir persönlich
diese entscheidung nicht leicht gefallen
denn auch nicht impfen hat
schwerwiegende konsequenzen
umso mehr ist mir eines wichtig der
ablauf der dinge in dieser woche zeigt
die bürgerinnen und bürger können darauf
vertrauen transparent informiert zu
werden
sie können darauf vertrauen dass
sorgfältig geprüft wird ereignisse auch
sehr seltene werden gemeldet sie werden
daraufhin untersucht ob es muster gibt
vergleichbare fälle und ob zusammenhänge
zur impfung erkennbar sind
und wenn das der fall ist dann wird
vorsorglich und vorausschauend reagiert
es geht um eine abwägung von nutzen und
risiken
das festgestellte risiko einer sehr
seltenen hirn venenthrombose wird
weiterhin als gering angesehen als die
folgen die nicht impfen hat wichtig für
das vertrauen ist jedoch die informierte
entscheidung dass informierte impfen
es gab mehrere optionen auch in der
europäischen diskussion auch in der
diskussion mit den bundesländern ich
habe mich sehr sehr klar dafür
ausgesprochen in den diskussionen dass
wir nun zügig weiter dass die
impfkampagne auch mit astrazeneca weiter
gehen kann
deshalb haben wir parallel zu ihrer
entscheidung mit der anpassung des
aufklärungs merkblattes für den astra
zenica im stoff für die patientinnen und
patienten begonnen
wir wollen heute noch in abstimmung mit
den ländern und dem
paul-ehrlich-institut diesen
aufklärungsbogen fertigstellen und
schnellstmöglich zur verfügung stellen
bis dahin kann die erfolgte aufklärung
auch handschriftlich ergänzt werden
durch die ärzte vor ort
denn unser ziel ist es und das ist das
gemeinsame ziel von bund und allen 16
bundesländern da schon morgen im laufe
des tages wieder mit impfungen mit astra
zenica in deutschland begonnen werden
kann
darüber sind wir uns einig bei bund und
ländern dass wir mit getragen und
unterstützt vom paul-ehrlich-institut
und auch die ständige impfkommission hat
sich mehrheitlich für ein solches
vorgehen ausgesprochen
das ist ein wichtiges gemeinsames
vielen dank meine damen und herren
der ausschuss für risikobewertung in der
pharmakovigilanz bei der europäischen
arzneimittelagentur ema hat sich heute
intensiv mit den aus deutschland und
anderen eu-staaten gemeldeten fälle von
thrombosen oft in verbindung mit einem
abfall der blutplättchen zahl
beschäftigt in deutschland haben wir mit
stand von heute mittag beim paul ehrlich
institut gemeldet 12 fälle von sinus fan
thrombosen alle bei frauen zwei davon
tödlich und größtenteils in einer
altersgruppe unter 55 jahren dazu ein
ähnlich gelagerter fall bei einem mann
ebenfalls tödlich verlaufen wir haben
von seiten des paul-ehrlich-instituts
festgestellt dass die anzahl dieser
fälle über der erwarteten anzahl ohne
impfung in deutschland liegt dieses
entsprechende ergebnis hat die
europäische arzneimittelagentur mit
einem ausschuss heute bestätigt genau
das ist auch bei der gesamtschau der
fälle in norwegen wo die inzidenz größer
ist als bei uns in deutschland sogar
übrigens im vereinigten königreich die
dabei getragen spanien unter anderen
ländern dänemark inklusive der deutlich
über der normalerweise zu erwartenden
anzahl und damit muss man sagen es
handelt sich um einen risiko signal
allerdings aufgrund des grenzwertes
aufgrund der wenigen fälle die wir haben
müssen wir feststellen dass es sich um
ein sehr seltenes signal handelt einen
sehr seltenen event und es ist unklar so
stellte ausschuss heute fest ob das
entsprechende event also die reaktion
der thrombosen tatsächlich ursächlich
mit dem um stoff in zusammenhang zu
bringen ist
deswegen stellt der ausschuss fest dass
das nutzen-risiko-profil weiterhin
günstig ist und demzufolge die impfung
weiter gehen können es wird aber
einen warnhinweis geben und das ist uns
wichtig dass es ein warnhinweis der auf
die besonderen symptome aufmerksam macht
die hier auftreten können in sehr
seltenen fällen und damit auch die
gewünschten aber auch die impfwilligen
vollständig darüber informiert auf
solche warnsignale wenn sie aus
derselben sind aufmerksam aufzupassen
und sich gegebenenfalls schnell bei
ärzten oder erstens vorzustellen
zum anderen wird sie auch einige
informationen für die ärzte gegeben
nämlich mehr aufmerksamkeit zu haben als
bisher auch schon dann wenn sich
entsprechende personen bei ihnen
vorstellen um danach zu sehen ob hier
signale für thrombosen sind und
eventuell abhilfe geschaffen werden kann
wir werden morgen von seiten des paley
ehrlich instituts auf basis der
verabschiedeten information von der
europäischen arzneimittelagentur dazu
einen hinweis auf unserer webpage zur
verfügung stellen
ich fass noch mal zusammen das ergebnis
der heutigen praxis um
ja es gibt ein signal für thrombosen in
zusammenhang mit zucchini auch übrigens
bei einer form von etwas disseminierte
blutgerinnung in den gefäßen die meisten
fälle unter 55 jahren auftreten
innerhalb von vier bis ungefähr 16 tagen
nach der impfung
das heißt dann wenn die üblichen in
fraktionen bereits abgeklungen sind
symptome die auftreten können sind
kurzatmigkeit schmerzen der wurst
schwellungen an armen und beinen
unterleibsschmerzen oder punktförmige
haupt blutungen diese symptome wenn sie
auftreten nach der impfung im zeitraum 4
tage und später sollten anlass seien
unverzüglich einen arzt bzw einer ärztin
aufzusuchen ärzten wird wiederum geraten
personen die sich mit ähnlichen
symptomen bei ihnen vorstellen unbedingt
anzufragen ob hier eine
impfung eine kurve die impfung mit dem
problem stoff astrazeneca vor kurzer
zeit erfolgt ist und dann auf anzeichen
von thrombose zu achten und entsprechend
zu handeln
insgesamt kann man sagen dass damit die
information für die impfwilligen da ist
es klar gestellt es handelt sich um ein
sehr seltenes ereignis und es ist klar
gestellt dass insofern die impfung
weiterhin ein positives
nutzen-risiko-profil tragen und weiter
geimpft werden kann
[Musik]
die entscheidung wurde verloren dadurch
dass wir den impfstoff nun zuerst einmal
ist in den letzten vier tagen montag
dienstag mittwoch donnerstag etwas
weniger geimpft worden wenn wir auf die
tages zahlen schauen als sonst das heißt
wir haben diese vier tage in diesen vier
tagen ein teil der sonstigen täglichen
impfung verloren wenn sie so nennen
wollen wichtig ist aber dass es sehr
vielen ländern gelungen ist in auch
vielen impfzentren mit biontech oder
moderner dosen die verfügbar waren das
auszugleichen festgelegte termine auch
tatsächlich stattfinden zu lassen dann
eben mit einer impfung mit einem anderen
impfstoff und die impfungen die nicht
habe stattfinden können die abgesagt
worden sind verschoben worden sind in
den letzten vier tagen die gilt es nun
und ich habe den eindruck das ist auch
das was die länder tun wollen und werden
die gilt es nun zügig nach zu wichtig
ist auch dass viele bundesländer die
termine mit astrazeneca teilweise für
die nächsten tage am montag abgesagt
haben aber eben nicht darüber hinaus
weil ja alle wussten dass es auch heute
möglicherweise eine immer entscheidung
gibt und das macht es eben möglich dann
auch jetzt wieder zügig in den tritt zu
kommen indem wir waren vor dieser
entscheidung das vorsorgliche aussetzen
jetzt die vier tage
das war aus unserer sicht notwendig um
sicherheit zu bekommen um informationen
zu bekommen
um aufklären zu können und jetzt gilt es
tatsächlich diese vier tage wieder
aufzuholen
von sascha meyer dpa mit blick auf den
impf gipfel morgen ist ein breiter
innenstadt in den arztpraxen ab der
woche vom 19 04 wie bisher angepeilt
jetzt noch realistisch für die
einschätzung welche impfungen welche
impfdosen zur verfügung stehen im laufe
des aprils ändert ja die heutige
entscheidung erst mal sozusagen nichts
im vergleich zur ursprünglichen planung
im gegenteil dadurch dass wir ab morgen
wieder beginnen mit astra zenica zu
impfen in deutschland stehen genau die
impfstoffe wieder zur verfügung zur
impfung der bevölkerung wie vor dem
vorsorglichen aussetzen am montag das
heißt also die planungen die wir hatten
und haben für den april
die können jetzt eben auch mit allen
drei impfstoffen umgesetzt werden und
wandern konkret in den arztpraxen
gestartet wird im beschluss der
gesundheitsminister steht ja spätestens
in der kalenderwoche 16
ab dem 19 04 das werde morgen mit der
ministerpräsidentin und präsidenten
beraten noch drei fragen an vatertag die
eine frage von gisela brühl
gesundheits informationsdienst in
welchem zeitraum sind die hirnwellen von
großen aufgetreten waren das nachmeldung
oder sind sie innerhalb eines kurzen
zeitraums also ab vergangenen freitag
auch vertreten hier muss man
unterscheiden einmal die symptomatik
diaz aufgetreten 4 bis 16 tage nach der
impfung
die meldungen sind bis montag
eingetroffen aber haben sich jetzt nach
erhöhte aufmerksamkeit noch etwas erhöht
wir sind noch dabei weitere meldungen zu
bekommen und nachzurecherchieren
bei den meldungen sichergestellt werden
muss dass es sich auch konkret wirklich
um das krankheitsbild der sinus
venenthrombosen handelt und natürlich
muss recherchiert werden
ob bei den entsprechenden fällen auch
andere ursachen infrage kommen oder
tatsächlich hier ein möglicher
zusammenhang zumindest zeitlich mit der
impfung vorhanden und zwei fragen von
algarve
was können sie über mögliche
autoimmunreaktion sagen die
möglicherweise zum thrombozyten abführen
wie kann so etwas im zweifel behandelt
werden es ist so dass tatsächlich dafür
behandlung zur verfügung stehen das
überlasse ich den ärzten
es ist so dass verschiedene mechanismen
momentan diskutiert werden wir sind noch
nicht so weit dass wir klarheit darüber
haben welche mechanismus hier zugrunde
liegen könnte fiel auch noch mal darauf
aufmerksam machen das ja der pratt heute
also der ausschuss bei der europäischen
arzneimittelagentur darauf aufmerksam
gemacht hat dass die ein klein wenig
erhöhte anzahl der gemeldeten fälle
einmal statistisch einfach fluktuieren
fluktuation sein könnte zum anderen aber
auch wirklich zu dir nimmst du verdient
sein könnte über die entsprechende
mechanismen machen wir uns gerade
gedanken auf die ärzte wissen genau wie
sie hier auf thrombosen zu achten haben
und entsprechende medizinische
eingreifen können letzte frage hat sich
welche bedeutung haben diese vorkommen
dass so viele weitere weg war
stocker ist es vorstellbar dass diese
reaktion auch dort aus wir haben im
moment keinen hinweis darauf dass die
beiden impfstoffe die wir haben ähnliche
signale ausgelöst haben das heißt sie
haben keine meldung dazu seitens des
paul-ehrlich-instituts vorliegen und
eine extraportion einfach auf alle weg
zur impfstoff ist glaube ich in diesem
fall nicht zulässig aber wenn das so
wäre würden wir das natürlich verfolgen
ich weise darauf hin dass sein ebenfalls
an loriots basierender vector impfstoff
gegen ebola zu lassen wurde auch
massenhaft angewendet wurde und sich
daraus keine entsprechenden signale
ergeben hatten
soweit also die pressekonferenz von
gesundheitsminister jens spahn und dem
präsidenten des paul-ehrlich-instituts
klaus cichutek ich fasse noch mal kurz
zusammen was die beiden da jetzt gesagt
haben also die impfungen das ist glaube
ich die wichtigste nachricht die
impfungen werden in deutschland schon ab
morgen morgen früh wenn es geht wieder
aufgenommen
zur zeit wird hinter den kulissen daran
gearbeitet dass das ins platz das zur
aufklärung dient ein update bekommt mit
genau dieser warnung das ist ein risiko
gibt es dass diese thrombosen aus
stetten können aber hat herr sparen
gesagt diese impfung kann auch
handschriftlich ergänzt werden so dass
also morgen tatsächlich wieder mit
diesem impfstoff geimpft werden kann er
hat betont dass die bürger innen
vertrauen können dass solche ereignisse
aufgenommen und gemeldet werden und auch
untersucht werden
er hat verteidigt dass es richtig war
die impfung auszusetzen bis aufklärung
da ist jetzt geht es aber mit vollgas
geben weiter es gab halt die frage ob
das das ganze jetzt gebremst hat
beziehungsweise wieder ins plan
weitergeht da hat ein bisschen
ausweichend geantwortet im april wird
auf jeden fall mit diesen drei
impfstoffe an geimpft waren die
hausärzte dran sind das soll morgen auf
dem impfgipfel beraten werden mit den
ministerpräsidenten der länder so wir
haben hier in unserem chat
einige wortmeldungen die in ganz
verschiedene richtungen gehen manche
befürworten das andere
überhaupt nicht so hier gibt es zum
beispiel eine frage die ich gleich an
unseren experten doktor christoph
spinner oberarzt am klinikum rechts der
isar in münchen und der pandemie
beauftragte und infektiologe also
durchaus bewandert in dieser ganzen
materie hoffentlich beantworten kann zb
von jewel nähe von grizzly was passiert
denn nun eigentlich mit den ganzen
astrazeneca dosen die während des
impfstoffs liegengeblieben sind müsste
davon etwas entsorgt werden ist das
bekannt die was können sie zu der
haltbarkeit des impfstoffes sagen
tatsächlich hatte sich die
bundesregierung dazu ja montag geäußert
es war vorgesehen dass die impfkampagne
pausiert wird das heißt aber auch dass
neben stoffe weder verboten noch ja für
die abgabe blockiert werden
also üblicherweise sind diese bei
kühlschranktemperatur haltbaren
impfstoffe mehrere wochen bis monate in
spa wir sprechen jetzt von vier tagen
die vergangen sind seit dem ersten
signal der pausieren und jetzt dem
möglicherweise ab morgen wieder erfolgen
den einsatz
also ich glaube wir könnten alle dosen
die bislang zur anwendung vorgesehen
waren auch weiter verimpft werden und
keine davon verworfen werden
aber was macht man denn jetzt wir haben
ja gerade gelernt dass die risikogruppe
besonders frauen und 55 sind was macht
man denn jetzt wenn man so eine frau ist
man hat eine berechtigung weil man zum
beispiel in einem beruf arbeitet der das
notwendig macht und das an den einzigen
impfstoff den man bei guten angeboten
bekommt ist astrazeneca hat man sagt das
risiko ist mir so groß muss man einfach
warten bis es dann was anderes gibt oder
wie läuft das dann wissen sie dass ich
glaube man darf sich vor allem an dieser
stelle nicht zu sehr verunsichern lassen
hat sicher tag hatte eben nochmal
hervorgerufen bis heute gibt es zwölf
meldungen der sehr seltenes - venus
sinus venenthrombose einer seltenen
erkrankung bei irgendwem gefäße bei 16
millionen kämpften astrazeneca tost also
insgesamt ein sehr sehr
unwahrscheinliches ereignis da wir
wissen dass frauen vor allem junge
frauen dreimal so häufig von sinus
venenthrombosen betroffen wie männer
besteht für sie zwar ein grundsätzlich
höheres risiko als
für männer auf der anderen seite sind
zwölf ereignisse auf 1,6 millionen
menschen nach wie vor sehr sehr selten
ein arzneimittel kein impfstoff ist
endlich gänzlich frei von risiken
ich würde in diesem fall empfehlen dass
sie die individuelle situation mit dem
im fernsehen oder dem behandelnden arzt
oder ärztin besprechen und eine
individuelle risiko nutzen abwägung
treffen sowie jens spahn jetzt auch in
der pressekonferenz vorgeschlagen hat
diese dann entsprechend hand schriftlich
zu dokumentieren dabei geht es ja nicht
nur darum die dokumentation vorzunehmen
sondern im ärztlichen gespräch mit den
betroffenen eine einzelfallentscheidung
zu brechen so gibt es jetzt in unseren
kommentaren einigen ärger und auch ja
sport so ein bisschen hilflos kommt mir
das ein bisschen vor also es geht hier
tatsächlich so kommentare die sagen 12
10 12 zu viel
12.12 zu viel also sind nichts mehr tote
gewesen und sind zwölf fälle gewesen
hier von uta zum beispiel leicht darüber
auch ein ähnlicher kommentar aber auch
eben die anleitung von olaf ohne diesen
impfstoff während der bald am ende von
daher bleibt uns keine andere wahl man
kann nur hoffen dass die lieferung
erweitert werden so mein gefühl ist so
ein bisschen bin ich ehrlich sein soll
herr doktor spinner dadurch dass wir
jetzt so sehr auf diese nebenwirkungen
gucken obwohl millionen mittlerweile
schon geimpft sind wird das ganze ein
bisschen erweitert also können sie
vielleicht mache ich weiß jetzt die
zahlen darauf dafür parat haben aber so
ein bisschen einordnen
bei anderen medikamenten bei selbst bei
so was wie aspirin also also bei
kopfschmerzmittel steht in den
packungsbeilagen ja schon auch stehen
schon sachen drin an nebenwirkungen die
auch nicht ungewöhnlich sind die häufig
erleben sie das dann am klinikum das
ganz normale gesunde menschen auf ich
sage mal ganz normale gewöhnliche
medikamente sehr außergewöhnlich
reagieren
ich glaube es geht gar nicht so sehr um
das außergewöhnlich reagieren auf
arzneimitteln aller arzneimittel haben
ein entsprechendes nebenwirkungsprofil
und viele davon sind in der
allgemeinheit gut bekannt so wie man zum
beispiel auch weiß und es wurde in den
letzten tagen ja auch viel verglichen
dass die anti baby pille die
wahrscheinlichkeit von venenthrombosen
und lungenembolien um den faktor vier
steigert wobei in der allgemein
bevölkerung jeder tausendste pro jahr
eine beinvenenthrombose erleidet also
man kann der verhältnismäßigkeit schon
nehmen sehr viel häufiger erkannt und
wir sehen bei uns ein klinikum rechts
der isar der tu in münchen auch jeden
tag beim venenthrombosen und auch häufig
lungenembolien jetzt ist die sehr selten
diskutierte sinus venenthrombose
natürlich eine ungemein seltene
erkrankung ich glaube ich würde es auch
von einer anderen seite betrachten am
ende bedeuten die ereignisse der letzten
woche auch dass die
sicherheitsüberwachung von zugelassenen
impfstoffen und arzneimitteln
funktioniert das alljährlich institut
nimmt seine aufgabe war die gemeldeten
nebenwirkungen von ärztinnen und ärzte
zu bewerten
darauf zu reagieren mit der europäischen
arzneimittelagentur eine bewertung
vorzunehmen und ich glaube es an der
stelle auch richtig einzuordnen die
aufgabe des paul ehrlich institutes an
dieser stelle ist ausschließlich die
bewertung der sicherheit des
arzneimittels die
gesamtgesellschaftliche einordnung
wieder um die der regierung deshalb der
bundesgesundheitsminister ja eben auch
noch mal betont und die bürgerinnen und
bürger müssen sich darauf verlassen
können dass die impfstoffe und
arzneimittel die wir einsetzen wirklich
sicher sind dass ärztliche individuelle
beratungsgespräch dient dazu risiko und
nutzen abzuwägen und für mich als
infektiologe und arzt sehr viele kurven
patientinnen und patienten behandelt hat
steht völlig außer frage dass jeder der
im moment zugelassenen impfstoff ein
ganz erhebliches positives nutzen profil
hat denn alle diese eben stoffe
verhindern übrigens empfahl von
astrazeneca bis zu 100 prozent
krankenhausaufnahme und tod durch coop
und gerade mit den steigenden fallzahlen
können davon auch wieder jüngere
menschen sehr viel häufiger betroffen
sein
trotzdem gibt es hier noch mal die
kritischen nachfragen zum beispiel von
mario wenn es eine häufung der fälle von
sinus thrombosen bei frauen unter 55
jahren gibt matthias euch kurz
augenblick dann dürfte jedoch nicht mehr
mit astra geimpft werden da haben auch
andere kommentatoren gerade darauf
hingewiesen großbritannien hat diesen
impfstoff wohl eher bei menschen über 65
eingesetzt hat dementsprechend auch wohl
weniger fälle da kann man doch auch
fragen hätte das gesundheitsministerium
das nicht vielleicht sagen soll
wir versuchen zumindest diesen impfstoff
er an gruppen zu geben die scheinbar
oder offenbar eher nicht von diesen
komplikationen betroffen sind also diese
berichterstattung über diese seltenen
möglicherweise als ein mittel
assoziierten wirkungen ist das
ungewöhnlich ist gerade der kobik 1901
recht bestehen dass großes öffentliches
interesse
und deswegen werden auch diese seltene
nebenwirkungen diskutiert tatsächlich
ist die sicherheitsüberwachung von
arzneimitteln nichts ungewöhnliches wir
erleben dass die tag als arzt bin ich
damit gut vertraut denn auch ich bin
verpflichtet ungewöhnlicher
arzneimittelwirkungen entsprechend zum
11 jetzt könnte man natürlich noch
detailliertere empfehlungen für den
einsatz der einzelnen impfstoffe
aussprechen
aber ich glaube man darf an der stelle
auch nicht vergessen ist heute gibt es
viel zu wenige impfstoffe es kommt auch
an vor allem den menschen die das
höchste risiko eines schweren verlaufs
also ältere menschen haben aber auch den
menschen die eben zb in
gesundheitsberufen oder in anderen
systemrelevanten berufen arbeiten früher
lebens angebot machen zu können
ich glaube wer jetzt als junge frau
sorge hat in der szene geheim stoffe
einzusetzen die der oder diejenige kann
sicher im beratungsgespräch mit dem arzt
die möglichkeiten besprechen
wir sprechen aber von so seltenen
ereignissen dass sich die
voraussetzungen auch für sehr schwierig
halte ihr jetzt in die also im
gesamtgesellschaftlich gesprochen
im verfehlungen einzuschränken denn das
würde auch bedeuten der impfstoff würde
dann der gruppe der jungen frauen
vorenthalten werden so hier geht es
jetzt auch die die anmerkung von
shakespeare also sollte doch möglich
sein dass wenn menschen nicht von diesem
impfstoff geimpft werden wollen lieber
den von bernd reck nehmen möchten dann
müssen die ärzte ist akzeptieren ich
glaube darum geht es auch gar nicht
jeder arzt akzeptiert immer die
entscheidung seiner patientinnen das
hoffe ich zumindest hier gab es aber
auch eine frage die ich gerade gesehen
habt ihr gegen die richtung kann man
nicht einfach die produktion von zb bei
contact ist ja der deutsche impfstoff
kann man nicht einfach erhöhen also wo
ist eigentlich das problem tatsächlich
ist genau das passiert also die am tag
hatte ein weiteres produktionswerk in
marburg in betrieb
genommen wird auch in diesem quartal
noch mit der zulassung des impfstoffes
einem weiteren m rna impfstoff in
tübingen gerechnet johnson & johnson hat
angekündigte mitte april sind sie
zugelassen der vakzine die nur ein mal
verimpft werden muss bereitzustellen
also wir rechnen jetzt damit dass in
kurzer zeit sehr viel mehr impfstoff zur
verfügung stehen
aber trotz allem ist
impfstoffherstellung sehr komplex die
erstellung stellt hohe anforderungen an
die produktionswerke und man kann sich
das nicht so vorstellen dass jeder
arzneimittelhersteller in der lage ist
diese technisch wirklich ausgefeilten
produktionsanlagen kurzfristig in
betrieb zu nehmen und übrigens müssen
auch dass die sicherheit erhalten bleibt
viele prüfschritte und bauliche
maßnahmen ergriffen werden
als wirklich sichere arzneimittel
entstehen deswegen ist der vorlauf auch
so lange und deswegen wurde ja auch
längst vor der zulassung von allen
hersteller mit der produktion begonnen
was übrigens auch dazu beiträgt dass ihr
so kurz nach der zulassung schon auf dem
stoff zurückgreifen können also hier ist
noch mal die erinnerung von daniel
einstein nochmal zum verhältnis wir
hatten bisher 2,6 millionen corona
infizierte davon mittlerweile 74 1000
tote ich glaube das ist ein plädoyer für
jede impfung die versuchen kann ja diese
todesrate wieder zu drücken
ich schaue es nochmal ob das hier andere
kommentare gibt in unseren geteilten
dort wo mir die kolleginnen helfen
hier ist die frage die heute auch schon
mal sind thrombosen wenn sie auftreten
auch behandelbar und wenn ja wie da
wurde ja gerade vom präsident des
paul-ehrlich-instituts darauf
hingewiesen dass wenn diese
nebenwirkungen auftreten oder diese die
symptome auftreten das dann sofort
gehandelt wird was würden sie als arzt
dann machen wenn jemand zu ihnen kommt
und sagt hier ich habe diese nadelstich
ähnlichen blutergüsse und ich habe
kopfschmerzen das was macht man dann
also da kommt es dann tatsächlich genau
drauf an von welcher form der thrombose
wir sprechen die sinus venenthrombosen
dies diskutiert wurden verursachen ganz
andere beschwerden als gewöhnliche arm
und bein venenthrombosen
die symptome sind jeder erzählen jedem
arzt gut bekannt es kommt dann darauf an
es gibt ultraschall methoden oder andere
methoden um gefäße darzustellen und um
bronzen zu suchen und abhängig von der
lokalisation und der ausprägung wird in
der regel blutverdünnern behandelt
abhängig vom der betroffenen
körperstellen den betroffenen gefäßen
unterschiedlich lange und die bei
besonders großen thrombosen gibt es
manchmal auch die möglichkeit die
truppen durch minimalinvasive verfahren
war sie wie in einem habe einfach es
gibt rund rohre reinigungsverfahren zu
entfernen aber die standardtherapie
besteht in der regel in der bluttat
übung muss also ich sehe hier im chat
weiterhin skepsis das ist aber auch
normal dass ich besonders diejenigen die
sich ärgern über eine entscheidung
besonders lautstark zu wort melden das
würde ich jetzt mal nicht als
repräsentativ nehmen aber wir haben
diesen einer diese sorge gesehen wir
haben die fragen gestellt wir stellen
fest
ab morgen geht die info mit astrazeneca
weiter wer diesen impfstoff nicht möchte
ist jederzeit frei den abzulehnen bei
einer impfung diese in freiheit besteht
ja weiterhin das besteht weiterhin keine
impfpflicht
und ich bedanke mich bei doktor
christoph spinner für die fragen und die
antworten die er uns gegeben hat und
sage erst mal schönen guten abend nach
münchen
ich danke ihnen alles gute und bleiben
gesund
das wünsche ich euch jetzt auch ich
würde sagen es war ein langer tag wenn
ihr den ganzen tag mit verfolgt habt was
heute alles passiert ist dann würde ich
ja sagen können wir ins bett gehen und
auf den ins gefühl morgen warten mal
schauen was da besprochen wird auf jeden
fall wird auch das vermutlich wieder
eine etwas längeres warten
wir sind auf jeden fall wieder hier für
euch da und ich sag das dahin macht euch
einen schönen abend macht gut und
tschüss